a founders decided to raise yeah and
they the question is do they start with
friends and family and if so what what
things should have found are consider
when they're going through that process
yeah how how uncomfortable are you
willing to make Thanksgiving Rosh
Hashanah or Christmas or July 4th or all
day right I mean if you're racing from
your friends and your family they're
hopefully going to get a great deal and
if it works out we have many examples of
Mark Zuckerberg parents put a little bit
of money into Facebook and they become
billionaires or you know
Bill Gates's parents I guess put money
into Microsoft and it worked out okay
for them as well but you really have to
be careful right because you're asking
your friends and family to take a flyer
now if your friends and family are
putting in five thousand dollars each
and it's ten of them and they all have
networks of a half million or a million
dollars they might very much want to
take that risk but you have to be
careful about that bootstrapping as we
saw on the previous one that's kind of a
high art if you can figure out a way to
bootstrap your way to getting the
product to market and then raise that's
another clear path to victory yeah I
think you also need to need to consider
that friends and family not as
sophisticated as usual investors we have
to be very honest with them going back
to the uncomfortable Thanksgiving yeah
you want to make sure that they know the
risks involved too I think it's a really
really important that you're so clear
with your family and friends letting
them know that it's entirely possible
you're going to lose all this money but
if you think of it another way and
you're raising this round and you feel
uncomfortable asking your friends and
family but then you build a unicorn
they're gonna be really upset with you
not going to them and asking and saying
hey you don't want to invest in this
company and potentially use all your
money but you could also you know that
was an exit yeah and to punch up what
you said letting them know it's possible
they're gonna lose all their money I
would even say it's probable right like
because we come into this with the
expectation as professional investors I
don't know six seven of our investments
go to zero out of every ten maybe seven
or eight and so and we're okay with that
because we've seen the wins so when we
strike out as you know grand slam home
run
which is what we tried to be as early
stage investors we're trying to hit home
runs part of hitting a home run is
really put in a little bit of you know
oomph behind that swing you got a swing
for the fences that means you could
strike out and I think friends and
family are maybe not sophisticated and
prepared for that
yeah and that also puts the
responsibility of making that a
sophisticated investment on the founder
you need to have a note or a safe safes
are really easy for founders to go
online and and just print one off yeah
you know it's making it you know a legal
document so that their friends and
family I protected down the road to will
be would be important yeah unpack that
for a minute a safe agreement or a note
what what is that for somebody who's
listening for the first time and wants
to raise fifty thousand from their
family and why is it important in your
mind that you do this in a buttoned up
fashion yeah so a safe is a simple
agreement for future equity so it's a
document that says I'm going to give you
some money you don't have to pay it back
it's not a debt instrument but when you
raise a priced round this money I'm
giving you is going to convert into
shares when you have when you start to
sell shares when we sell securities this
will convert into securities in your
company and a note is very is similar
but it's a debt instrument it has
interest attached to it but it the the
reason I say a safe and that it's a
little bit easier is because a note
could be up to you know 15 20 pages of a
legal document which can be a little bit
overwhelming one for a first-time
founder or even a founder who's done it
before but is really new or it's early
in their business and and then also you
know a family member isn't going to read
or understand all of the terms that
might come with like you know a
convertible note so a safe is is really
read similar similarly to a term sheet I
mean it's really really basic and not
challenging to just google a quick term
and know what you're signing it's also a
great idea to have this buttoned up I
guess because if you do want to raise
from Angels or go to an accelerator you
may want to go to launch accelerator or
TechStars or Y Combinator you want to
have your legal documents in order
anytime you have to go back and clean up
it's an easy way for an investor to back
out and say you know what there's
material differences between what you
told me or this structure doesn't seem
like one I want to invest in we see this
come up in diligence all the time in the
accelerator correct Jason yeah
yeah so it's the the smoother a
diligence process goes the less reasons
there are for an investor to pass I mean
there are at an early stage there are so
many reasons to pass on an investment
and you want to try to keep those at
them as tight as possible so making sure
there are vesting schedules making sure
that your your bank account is clean of
any personal personal charges those are
the sorts of easy things to keep things
as clean as possible yeah to sort of
further that to when we go into
diligence and making sure that you have
an early investment you know buttoned up
with documents we look at bank
statements and if we see a hundred
thousand dollars and no documents to
back it up that's concerning because
that person could also come back and say
oh we'll you agreed to you know X Y & Z
when the founder is is you know refuting
that so you just you want two things
clean and legal if you're gonna do it
you might as well do it right
that's exactly is I think the message we
want to make sure all founders know is
if you're gonna take the time to build a
company you should come to it with the
assumption that hey this could become a
unicorn if you are going the venture
route if you are going to be a high
skill business which means you don't
want somebody who you gave $100,000 to
and they said it was a loan coming back
and saying that wasn't alone that was
for 20% of the company we agreed and
there's no paperwork or there's an email
that's not worded properly this could be
the death blow of the to the company and
it happens it's happened many times we
uncover a lot of things in diligence
let's talk about diligence for an unpack
that for one more moment when we look at
friends and family and then also you
know getting into an accelerator what
are the short items on that due
diligence list and what do we find are
the most common things that are wrong
the the mingling of personal expenses as
you've seen
to be a reoccurring theme sometimes
people get $25,000 from their friends
and family and then they put it towards
their apartment I had that happen once
where like they were working out of
their apartment and I was like okay what
percentage of the apartment are using
because that's what the IRS wants to
know and so you just you can those
things aren't deathblows but they do
need to be cleaned up what are the other
things that come up in diligence I'm
sure you both have great stories yes so
the things that we typically go through
are a cap table bank statements customer
references and the org chart - to an
extent as well so most common on a on a
cap table kind of the two things that
come to mind
number one the founding team not having
a vesting schedule so founders just
giving themselves all of their shares
and we can talk a little bit about why
that is potentially an issue and then
the other piece is you know to to your
point about not having your investors
well documented so who are the investors
when did they invest was it on a
convertible note or safe what was the
what was the valuation cap was there an
interest was their interest associated
with the note or the safe having all
that those items lined out very
important for downstream investors when
we start talking about VCS great any
other horror stories Ashley when we look
at this due diligence process things
that can kill a deal things that people
should be cognizant of I mean I the red
flags I've seen which I don't think are
malicious just ill-informed are it's
just a messy PNL it's no cogs they're
not showing any cogs there's no costs of
goods at all in a lot of these companies
which is obviously false or they have
really spiky expenses some months
they're spending a hundred thousand
dollars in the next three months they
spend $3,000 you know and it's because
they're not they're you know either not
amortize in costs out properly or
they're just not you know they're not
adequately categorizing where these you
know expenses should be yeah you know
I've seen payroll as a non you know as a
non payroll expense in PNL so it's just
how does the IRS feel about that one
yeah you know it's it's not
in its you don't know what you don't
know yeah when you're you know a new
founder or founder in general you just
you don't know what you don't know but
that it's it does fall back to you so
yeah being informed you know knowing you
know just buying some accounting
software get some you know and and just
playing around with a with it for you
know an hour or two will be very very
help